what is the role of scientific
prediction well there are different
explanations for why societies get into
end times and they propose often the
opposite mechanisms for The observed
data so what we need to do what is a
scientific approach is that we take
those explanations translate them into
mathematical theories that's very
important because
human societies and dynamical systems
with many interlinked parts and
understanding how different little
nudges or pushes result in different
outcomes requires mathematical apparatus
foreign
[Music]
it is my distinct pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast one of my favorite thinkers
on society's coming apart yes that's
actually a field now thanks to him
University of Connecticut professor and
author of the new book end times Elites
counter Elites and the path of political
disintegration Peter turchin welcome
Peter thank you Andrew Peter uh I cited
your book ages of Discord in my last two
books uh you have somehow gotten
yourself uh wrapped up in the
dissolution disintegration of societies
but you came to this from a completely
different discipline you came it from I
want to say as an uh ecologist in study
or of systems uh can you talk about how
you wound up in this field yes I was
trained as a theoretical biologist and I
worked on population Cycles in insects
uh mice deer and settings and when I
turned 40 I essentially had a midlife
crisis but instead of divorcing my wife
I divorced my science and married a new
one essentially I wanted to to see it I
wanted to encounter some challenges and
studying history from the point of view
of complexity science sounded like a
challenge enough for me and that's what
I've been doing for the past 25 years
and so you've help to start a new field
that's called Clio Dynamics can you
describe what Clio Dynamics is yes
essentially when I started working in
became interested in history I realized
that history was the last subject that
has not yet been mathematized other
social sciences especially economics but
also political science sociology they
had mathematical models and they were
testing those models with data but in
history this was not done in a
systematic manner so I and my colleagues
came up with this name Cleo Dynamics
Cleo is the muse of history of course
and Dynamics is the science of change in
what is history history is about how
things change in time so Dynamics the
dynamical approaches are natural for
applying to history and by the way I am
not only studying why societies break
down in fact I study both how come we
live in large-scale complex societies
almost 100 percent of people today lives
in such
societies are organized as States but
these societies are only 5 000 years old
for 95 percent of our evolutionary
history humans lived in small-scale
simple societies and then suddenly there
was this uh incredible Evolution so that
is one of the two big questions and the
second question of course is why do such
societies periodically enter into end
times periods of social dysfunction
political disintegration sometimes
leading to pretty dire outcomes it's
true I misspoke Peter because you talk
about how there are extended periods of
integration followed by extended periods
of disintegration so it's not like you
just studied them coming apart you study
them coming together and you do have
some positive recommendations as to how
you can better integrate Society yeah
and and times enzymes are also times of
new beginnings
amen I'm all about that for sure it's
like we might as well start something uh
positive if you kind of if you can sense
that things are not trending in a good
direction so your work first hit my
radar in part because you made what
seemed like a bold prediction about 10
years ago where people asked you uh what
you saw coming down the pike and you saw
a very very rough political time now
this is back before Trump before a lot
of things
um so what were the variables that made
you think that we were in for this uh
rough period politically but let me
first step back and explain why I made
this prediction this was not a prophecy
it was a scientific prediction what is
the role of scientific prediction well
there are different explanations for why
societies get into end times and they
propose often the opposite mechanisms
for The observed data so what we need to
do what is the scientific approach is
that we take those explanations
translate them into mathematical
theories that's very important because
human societies and dynamical systems
with many interlinked parts and
understanding how different little
nudges or pushes result in different
outcomes requires mathematical apparatus
all right so that's the first step to
translate the different theories into
predictions and then we need massive
data to test those predictions my
colleagues and I will have been building
massive databases to do this and we had
used a method we call retroduction
essentially this is predicting what
happened in the past this is a true
scientific prediction because you don't
know until you actually look uh what
happened to a particular society and so
that is a severe test of theories but at
the same time when I saw what uh Trends
were developing in the United States
this was around 2008 or so I actually
truthfully I was shocked because it
suddenly dawned on me that United States
stepped on this path to political
disintegration fragmentation already by
1980s essentially
and therefore I thought that this offers
us
in my motto that I ran forward suggested
that it would be around 2020 early 2020s
when things over a variety of Trends
would come to a head and that would be
the most likely time for some kind of a
social rupture to happen and so I used
this as a way to test Theory and see
whether it would be true and alternative
theories by the way I always always test
predictions against alternative theories
alternative theories was saying that
actually things were getting better you
know for example uh Stephen uh pincer
you know Max Roser and they all have
been pointing to the trends that have
been getting better and better but my
theory said that there is there's going
to be Trend reversal all right and so
that's uh why uh this is a good example
of scientific prediction because you
have different Theory is predicting
different things and then we waited 10
years and unfortunately we saw what we
saw well the the model took in a bunch
of data points and the data point struck
me as fascinating
um where your model included things like
average income
um growth or lack of growth but also
things like average height uh visits to
National Monuments Trust of public
institutions uh Elite over production
you had a bunch of inputs that I had not
considered before though when I thought
about them they made sense to me I
thought average height was incredible
life expectancy was another and when I
was running for president I would say to
folks look life expectancy has gone down
for the last three years I mean that's
pretty basic that's fundamental you know
we're not living as long
um and so you're seeing these gains and
these riches but they're not being
enjoyed by the average American and if
any anything the average American in
some quarters is more likely to drink
themselves to death or die of a drug
overdose or have other problems and they
certainly didn't feel included in any
good things that were happening uh
somewhere else so can you talk about
what data points went into the model and
how you determined which ones were
relevant yes the ideas about what the
data to look at came from historical
analysis we at this point when I wrote
the book we had about 100 societies past
societies sliding into crisis and then
emerging from it now we are approaching
200 of our sample size and so what we
see is the common theme on the road to
crisis is Elite overproduction all right
so that's even more important than than
what we call popular immigration that
can be measured with things like life
expectancy and things like that so
perhaps it's this is a good time for me
to explain what I mean by Elite
overproduction
yeah yeah please it's an important idea
in your book so let's break it down
first like what the heck do you mean by
Elite
exactly who are the elites um simply put
it's a neutral thing it's not good
people bad people it's simply a small
proportion of the population that
concentrates Social Power in their hands
so think about the preferable one
percent in America although it's it's a
little bit more complicated than that
but also you know Mandarin class in
Imperial China or if you go back into
the past military and ability in England
France so these are people with power
and the next question you want to ask
about Elite is the Dynamics of it how
are they reproduced and recruited that's
the key question there's always more
people who want to be in to acquire
Elite positions the positions of power
so we call such uh Elite one abuse Elite
aspirants all right and that's uh normal
and some competition is good however
sometimes in societies
um the number of elite aspirants begins
to grow rapidly and completely
overwhelms the number of power positions
we saw this happen in 2016 when there
were 17 Republican candidates in the
presidential primaries and
um there's about one individual started
breaking rules and it was followed by
others and very soon things they
generated into something that nobody
expected but that's a normal outcome you
see this in medieval societies we see
this in periods preceding such
um you know breakdowns like French and
Russian revolutions American Civil War
is another example in all the run-ups to
this huge crisis there was a various uh
severe a problem of elite overproduction
and that is what led to the breakdown of
social norms and eventually it led to
Bloodshed 600
000 people killed in the American Civil
War for example
foreign
some things we do in public some things
we do in private and we certainly would
like to be able to know that when we're
alone we're actually getting our privacy
online is the same thing your online
privacy is just as important as in the
real world that's why I use expressvpn
when I'm online because I don't want my
internet service provider to know every
website I visit nor do I want them to
sell my data to Big tech companies
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
connection a tunnel between your device
and the internet no one can see it it
works on any device all you have to do
is fire up the expressvpn app click one
button it's as easy as that I recommend
this Fortune 500 companies use
expressvpn for good reason and you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
free by going to expressvpn.com Yang
that's
expressvpn.com Yang for three extra
months free
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
yeah what are the more foreboding
predictions is that according to your
model there's a diminution in the number
of uh Elites so you look at that being
like well how do you shake that number
so let me dig in a second when you say
um that uh the definition of elite it
certainly includes money
um you describe America as a plutocracy
uh which I find pretty inarguable
I don't find problematic
um but when you talk about the elite
you're not solely talking about people
with big bank accounts there are other
forms of power exactly they're they're
really four forms of Social Power
um first of all is coercion on military
power then it's economic Elites money
wealth then we have more subtle form of
power which is administrator for
political power and finally the softest
power is ideological power which can be
very powerful too and what happens is
that different societies tend to
specialize in different types of Elites
right so for example medieval societies
they were they were ruled by militaries
since Knights right but uh our
Democratic societies are typically ruled
by the Coalition between economic and
administrator for political Elites but
the relative power changes that in those
two
um members of the Coalition in the
United States the United States it's
actually quite unusual for oecd
countries because of such dominance by
the economic Elites so we're thinking
about people with wealth not just the
one percent but also one tenth of one
percent or even one uh one percent of
one percent so these are the people who
concentrate huge amount of wealth and
wealth is translated into Power yeah so
again your four forms of Power are
physical which you hope is not as much
of a factor in the US because the state
has something of a quasi Monopoly on a
coercive uh armed might then you have
economic which I think people understand
and then you have bureaucratic which is
who's actually running various
institutions or mechanisms and then the
fourth is ideological or soft power
which you include say includes having
lots of social media followers uh you
know that that would fall into
um the the soft power category story
which I agree can be very important more
traditional think about religious
leaders in fact there is one country
Iran where the ideological
Elites are dominant all right but also
it's people who write for New York New
York Times columns and the people who
have huge following uh on on their you
know podcasts or you know blogs so by
these definitions Peter uh would you
consider yourself an elite
I I am essentially a 10 percenter all
right so I these are
described as sort of lower rank Elites
so we we have power in the sense that
um we can uh we have power over our own
lives all right so I for example don't
have to do I don't have to move to a
place where I don't want to move I don't
take I don't need to take a job that I
don't like and things like that but I
don't have a lot of power over other
people and of course you have to realize
that there is no sharp boundary it's
well in medieval societies there was a
shark boundary you you you either had
your Noble had a patent and so on or you
were peasant and so on but in our
societies the boundary is much softer
and so the power
grades uh the more wealth you have and
higher you are in the administrative
hierarchy the more power you have there
is no sharp boundary you know what's
what's funny Peter is I I was reflecting
on this a little bit and one of the
problems which I guess gets us into a
lead over production is I know a lot of
people who would technically be
considered elite under your definition
who don't feel themselves to be elite
it's kind of one of the problems isn't
it well we have this mythology in the
United States that we live in a
classless society and uh therefore you
know people don't want to admit that
they have huge amounts of power but um
I'm a scientist uh we I write in the
book that we want to stay away from
ideologies and we want to study how
Society works in the most objective and
even-handed Manner and the truth is if
you look at the United States you
certainly see that the proverbial one
percent is a real thing not everybody of
the of the top one percent in the wealth
exercises their power they have that
power but they don't exercise it perhaps
because they just amuse themselves
flying to reach to Porsche Resorts you
know and things like that but they do
have that hour if they wish to exercise
it whereas I don't I don't have enough
wealth to buy Senators you know to
influence political process and things
like that
foreign
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
so Peter when I see Elite overproduction
what comes to mind for me is you have a
lot of people getting college degrees
and advanced degrees and then not enough
spots for them uh whatever the heck that
means and there are a couple of examples
that I've spoken on before for example
the number of tenure track academic
positions is at best staying the same
but you keep producing a gajillion new
uh phds every year and so it's like
they're not going to be able to become
professors in the way that you you'd
imagine so that's an evident one there
are less evident ones where you are
producing tons of college graduates who
may or may not have the kind of secure
livelihoods uh that they might have
expected is that what you mean by a lead
over production primarily is just we're
producing tons more people with various
credentials who then get frustrated and
pissed off Barkley what what you have
you're describing is people in fact
let's let's step back and talk about
immigration because this is going to be
critical in order for me to explain uh
you know to answer your question so one
of the problems you note is that of the
wealth that's been produced in the U.S
over the last several decades it seems
to have collected in the hands of the
top uh tenth of one percent top one
percent and to a lesser extend the top
10 percent and uh the average American
has seen barely anything
um over that period and by the way the
the cost of Education or the cost of
Health Care cost of housing keep going
up and up and in some cases are totally
unattainable for the average American in
a way that they would have been
attainable a couple Generations ago
because you know cost of public
education maybe you had the GI Bill
stuff was pretty accessible and now it's
not
um and now immiseration
so for example a household of uh in the
working class so people without college
degrees if they want uh how how many
years they need to work to pay a college
average college for their daughter or
son well it used to be about a year or
so now it's uh nearly four years so you
can see that this is a huge them
a measure of inflation doesn't really
capture uh important things like
education Medical Care and housing so
those are important aspects of the of
middle class life but okay so the the
question is
um first of all why does a little
reproduction develop in societies all
right and so here uh what we observe in
one pesticide after another is that as
we were talking about that they have
that tend to go through about
essentially long past minus periods of
Integrative periods when internal order
and peace and things are working working
pretty well what happens typically is
that the ruling class gets used to these
conditions and then they become tempted
to reconfigure economy in ways that
would benefit them rather than the rest
of the population and why well just
because they can it's the iron law of
oligarchy and this is what happened in
the United States in the late 1970s
we've all seen this graph where the
productivity of American workers keeps
going up and up and then in the late
1970s prior to that the wages have been
going up and then boom there's a flat or
stagnating or even declining and so this
is what and so uh this is what has
driven in miseration which is a real
thing because you you mentioned
the overdoses and alcoholism well the
technical name for it is the death of
Despair it also includes exercise and
also people become more likely to have
accident fatal accidents that's because
they don't care about life they're
feeling that they are losing ground so
much that uh that they do all those
things so that's a miseration and when I
started giving talks
um about this I was saying that of
course we live in postmouth region times
and therefore I would not expect to see
the typical
um
phenomenon that we see in previous uh
end times which is the decline in life
expectancy and I was wrong because as
you said around 2017 this is the first
Decline and now it's just we are we have
lost like more than 20 years of progress
in life expectancy in America so this is
a real thing all right but then uh what
happens to all that extra wealth that
workers are generating that's that
drives the what I call the wealth pump
it's the reversible of pump the
transverse reaches from the poor to the
ridge essentially and so it is quite
remarkable that over this 40 year period
of time the number of uh Uber rich like
people who have 10 million dollars or
more of wealth it has exploded it has
grown tenfold
I mean this is staggering the population
has grown 40 percent with the number of
uh of the chameleonaires grew uh tenfold
so so that is actually one of two
important pipelines that drive Elite
over production so we are actually going
to circle back to the question we are
asked so first of all
um because
um in the United States the elites uh
the political if you want to become a
senator or even President right there
are two routes first of all you need to
have a lot of wealth all right second
one we'll talk about that later you need
certain educational credentials all
right the wealth uh route is essentially
some proportion of those uh of those a
very rich class they want um to
translate their wealth into political
office so it's not just Donald Trump
it's also Michael Bloomberg also think
about uh unsuccessful candidates like
Steve Forbes I don't know how many
people remember his uh bid for
presidency so and so that is one
pipeline that drives overproduction of
elite aspirants for political positions
in this case the second pipeline is um
uh even more important in numerically
you how if you want if you don't have
wealth um or how do you want how do you
get into
um into political office well the best
route is uh is a lawyer degree and so
we've been
producing low degrees and those new is
holding low degrees compete in for the
positions all right but the third and
very subtle result of the wealth pump is
that because of the immigration of the
majority of the population that
increases the desire of more ambitious
individuals to leave it and at least get
into ten percent so these are the three
thing that things that they're all
rooted in the wealth bump so that's the
that's sort of at a very basic level
what's a fundamental level what's
driving things
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been a mattress guy because
it was common sense to me you spend up
to eight hours a day sleeping more if
you're lucky and so the right mattress
can make a huge difference what the heck
does it mean for something to be the
right mattress for you you can take the
Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes sent to
your door you know they believe in their
product because they offer a 100 night
trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty to
try out your new mattress I endorse this
mattress because I literally sleep on it
and so do my kids there are a couple
mattresses in the house and this is the
one that they seek out even though it
was made for me it's so good that even
my kids are like hey they feel like it's
made for them but it's not it's a number
one mattress picked by GQ and wired and
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep Starts
Now
[Music]
yeah most Americans can sense some of
what you're talking about certainly in
terms of uh stable life getting harder
and harder to come by I mean there are
stats on Americans choosing not to have
kids because they may or may not be able
to support them in that way so you have
a very compelling uh picture of what
comes next there's something called the
political stress index that uses some of
these variables and says that we're now
at a higher level of political stress
than at any time since uh the first
Civil War or the only civil war we hope
it's the only civil war and in your book
end times you talk about what you think
is coming now uh according to the data
and the model so if you had to describe
to someone what you think is coming next
what what do the next number of years
hold in store first of all I want to
make a comment that getting into crisis
it's like a ball rolling down a narrow
Valley so there's no really no place to
go which is why the since which is why I
was fairly confident about making
prediction back in 2010 but once you get
to the crisis
um you are on the cusp and all kinds of
avenues open that's by the way why we
need so such a massive number of
historical case studies is because
there's so much variability in how
pastors I just have exited from crisis
we need to understand why some of them
end up in complete collapse you know
most of the outcomes are fairly dire
quite bloody but the question becomes
then how do be a move
our society in a more favorable
Direction so here uh we really don't
care about prediction that much
right what we care about is we want to
understand what we need to do uh to
avoid uh the really bad outcomes and
this is where the science of History
Cleo Dynamics can be very useful it's
much very useful in his cusp uh
predicting the future is uh is not that
useful but predicting uh trying to
figure out uh what we need to do is uh
is the useful thing well Peter there's
one thing in your book and you just
mentioned it where you said look uh when
you get into this crisis mode it takes
years and years and years and so one of
the things you said in your book was
like according to the model even if you
did do some good things on the policy
side at this point you're still going to
hit the Rocks because the the the
boulder has been rolling downhill for so
long
um is that accurate yeah it strikes me
as accurate by the way like you know you
know like we're at a point now where uh
I I feel like
um the conflict is rising and it's
beyond
um now I'm all for various positive
policies I mean you know dedicated
um uh fair share of my career to try to
make some of these changes
um and my personal life but uh but the I
I thought that uh we're kind of in the
throes of history and the the negative
Force has been building for quite some
time yeah exactly it's the social system
has quite a lot of inertia so now that
we are in a crisis what we we can do is
a new negotiate or navigate a way out
that is going to be less bloody than uh
what's uh actually possible to happen
many people look at the summer of 2020
well including January 2021 and think
that okay this was a spike now we are
past the worst but what our historical
analysis shows is that typically this
periods uh run of civil disturbance and
political violence they typically run 10
to 20 years all right
sometimes very few examples shorter
sometimes if you have complete collapse
then essentially it's until something a
new comes around all right but um it
takes time for these things to work
their way through the system all right
and so the decisions that we
collectively and especially are
political leaders will be making in the
next few years are are going to have an
effect right uh we are still going to be
in crisis but first of all that will
determine uh how we exit this crisis but
also more importantly we need we have
there would be another Crisis coming
along if we don't
reconfigure our social system back to
where it is much more sustainable so a
turbulent 10 to 20 years makes sense to
me intuitively if that's the historical
pattern
um I I am now trying to put forward a
more positive brand of politics that
gets beyond the two-party back and forth
that I think is going to be kind of the
flash point for a lot of this turbulence
uh you know it's going to be animating
um the hostility in various ways now
there are a bunch of Common Sense things
I think uh you'd want
us to be doing
um and the the obvious thing is hey if
you got this this uh aggregation of
wealth and resources in the hands of uh
relative sliver of the population maybe
you should spread that out some you know
maybe there are things you can do that
uh spread the general prosperity and you
do have uh historical examples and
international examples of countries that
came together and said you know what
we're gonna actually try and spread the
benefits
um heck even the U.S in an earlier time
period uh resembled that and so if you
had to just make a you know a couple of
policy recommendations that you think
hey either before during or after uh the
this turbulent period like this is
what's going to bring us back together
uh like what does that list look like
well I'm I'm not going to make specific
policy recommendations let me explain we
do have uh several positive examples and
one of them you mentioned it's uh United
States during the Progressive and then
you deal era it turns out out if you
look at the data that 1920 or so there
was a huge Peak plus minus several years
a huge peak of instability in the United
States which was quite similar to 1850s
but this time around the elites managed
to avoid another civil war and what they
did they essentially shut down the
wealth pump that was driving the pro the
problems during the 19th century
1850s and 19th century was very similar
to what we saw
in the last two or three decades even
there was a yielded age you know we are
now the second year that age and you
know things like that and there are
other examples like the churches period
in Great Britain like mid 19th century
and so on and so forth so um but we but
we don't just want to take those
examples and follow them we don't want
to do exactly the same that the New Deal
did what they did well first of all they
gave power to workers to organize and
negotiate they imposed minimum wage
which kept and it kept increasing it and
also they taxed the hell out of people
with high incomes
so we don't have to do exactly the same
thing what we need to do we need to shut
down this wealth pump so we need to get
uh worker wages back on track together
with the general economy all right but
how we do it uh redistribution is
certainly one way but also just simply
increasing the minimum wage it is
mind-boggling to me that you have a
democratic
um president in power and the minimum
wage is still the same beautiful 7.25
cents and it's in real terms it keeps
decreasing all right so there are some
obvious things but the specific
um the specific mixture of what we need
to do this is the job for you guys
um yeah a job for us yes challenge
accepted Peter well uh you know I'd say
some of the obvious things would be
um trying to increase our life
expectancy because if a negative life
expectancy is correlated to to like this
uh crisis then maybe we should try and
lengthen people's lives pretty
straightforward who could be against
that
um maybe try and make it so that our
average height stays the same or goes up
I mean I thought average height was
hysterical I mean it makes sense when
you think about like if you have a an
unhappy population that isn't getting
its basic needs met then maybe they're
not as tall or strong or healthy I will
also say I'm a parent I have two boys
and I'm constantly telling them like eat
like you know you've only got one shot
to grow
so so I get it on that level but I I'd
be trying to take shots at uh these
variables that you describe uh public
trust you know that's a negative
variable that that's in your model so
like how can we get people to trust
institutions again that's going to be a
lot
um so there are a lot of things that we
should do
thank you
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of Jen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who's started in
an app to solve that are the founders of
Bloom Bloom app is the award-winning
Financial Services app it's made by
young people for young people I've met
the founders they are great guys who
want to make you or the people in your
life who are young and just starting out
financially literate check it out at
bloomapp.com and there's a special offer
for listeners to this podcast 15 in free
stock and one month subscription for
free go to bloomapp.com Yang to sign up
today bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the
dark in terms of financial literacy
let's get educated people bluemap.com
yang
[Music]
foreign
I'm curious Peter how has the response
been to your work because you are one of
the real handful of people doing this
work there was a period x years ago
where if you were to mention something
like oh we might get embroiled in like
another civil war that was completely
off the table in certain quarters
certain quarters would be like that's
nuts you're nuts
um and to the extent that people were
saying that it was people who were let's
say
um kind of ultra conservatives maybe or
like you know separatists all right
types but now
um folks all over the ideological
Spectrum are looking at and saying wow
that's a real possibility like what uh
has has your experience been over the
last really number of years that you've
been making this case
well uh yes exactly
initially there's quite a lot of
disbelief hell I um it's hard for me to
imagine that you would have something
like American Civil War in this country
now as a human being right but uh as a
scientist I know that in previous
previous pre-conscious periods people
also did not believe that they were
going to get into you know French Nobles
in 1780s had no idea that they would be
put under the guillotine you know and so
on and so forth Americans in 1850s did
not think that there would be a uh such
a bloody Civil War but it happened
anyway just because we cannot imagine it
it does not mean it can't happen and we
um humans have been becoming more
civilized in a sense all right we care
more about uh inflicting harm and
killing other people but that may not be
yet enough because if you look at it
there is a number of very more than a
society just thinking UK in the 1970s
Northern Ireland who would have thought
that this uh Democratic and uh intensely
civilized society would get into a you
know into a civil war essentially all
right so um we need to be very serious
about uh about this possibility and if
we are paradoxically then we can
we have a higher chance of avoiding it
because that's the other thing in the
successful cases
that did not lead to Civil War or
revolution
what happened was the elites became very
uh frightened essentially and they
thought that Revolution was imminent and
that was a huge force that pushed them
to to
adopt the necessary things I don't know
when you you are talking to other uh
politicians and people like that do you
see that um there is this feeling that
we've got to do something
um is that getting uh taking hold or let
me put it this way yesterday I checked I
went and looked at your party platform
and you are I think very rightly talking
about how you're not left or right all
right and that's by the way that's how
typically societies exit this um this
crisis because they pull together they
uh during the the hatchet and between
the different parties and uh and they
essentially Forge uh some kind of a
cooperation all right but in order to do
that uh there has to be enough
understanding that we are in the same
boat rather then it's their other side
of the aisle that's the evil people you
have to destroy them and back and forth
so what what's your feeling about where
we are in this process
oh thank you Peter uh this is my mission
um and in some ways your work is
heartening uh though who wants to go
through 10 to 20 years of bad times
before everyone gets exhausted and then
decides to come together
um one of the major problems right now
is that if you talk to someone in one
party or another they do tend to see it
in terms of partisan conflict uh and
it's oh I gotta fend off the other side
um and that's more important than
addressing some of these root problems
uh I I think that we can hopefully with
the forward party provide this Coalition
building uh and get beyond the the back
and forth and then address some of the
root causes uh the immiseration uh and
uh this is by the way I mean why I ran
for president in the last cycle
um and I had a vision that hey you know
we could get in front of this thing uh
and start trying to put out the fires I
still want to try and put out the fires
it's just now I will be honest with you
um I I do feel like uh things might get
worse before they get better
so the the question is
um is what the time frame is on when we
can start doing the positives
um like what the vision you present
um I like I can imagine growing conflict
and then also growing interest and this
is something that you say in the book
which interested me a lot was you said
look uh they're actually going to be a
lot of people that get pushed into
um the can't we build a coalition Camp
because they're going to be turned off
and disgusted by the conflict
yeah yeah but unfortunately typically
the conflict would have to get even
worse before even worse yeah before this
uh realization takes root naively I
would like to think that we can learn
from the past mistakes of past societies
and avoid that stage but realistically
um
it may be inevitable I agree with you
that I don't see also right now I see
mostly most of the energy is
um uh is uh put into the international
uh in fighting rather than trying to
address the Deep causes yeah there are
figures trying to change it I consider
myself one of them
um we're just going to do the best we
can and it's how it does seem like again
I found your work
um both daunting and heartening
simultaneously
um because like I can see how what we're
doing is is the right move in the right
direction and you know I think the
energy around us is just going to grow
but unfortunately it might grow because
the conflict gets worse like that that
could be the order of things do you see
any
um people on in either Republican or the
American party who are currently
politicians who might be more amenable
to this type of a message
yeah very much so I mean we talk to them
all the time and we're actually
converting people who are office holders
at various levels uh State levels the
mayor or two Mayors um so we're we're
and if you talk to them privately by the
way a lot of them actually are are
interested and aligned it's just they
don't feel like it serves them
politically to step forward just yet
yeah yeah that makes sense but but the
average American is very very into what
we're doing if they think it can work
um and it sounds like again I mean the
history is on our side for better for
worse
yeah yeah According to some studies the
degree of polarization within the
non-eliad population is actually not as
huge as many people assume so
fascinating Peter we'll have to have you
back
um to talk about uh how to knit us back
together
um Peter turchin the author of end times
Elites counter Elites and the path of
political disintegration you've
influenced my work uh profoundly uh
anyone who's read my books uh knows that
um I I've cited you uh often and I hope
that people pay attention to both your
work and your recommendations
thank you Andrew for having me on your
podcast
foreign